في خطاب امام انصاره بعد مثوله امام
المحكمه ترامب يعتبر قضيه الوثائق محاوله
لتزوير الانتخابات المقبله
قتل وجرح بهاجمات طائرات مسيره استهدفت
مقر سلاح المدرعات في الخرطوم
يهدد باستخدام اسلحه تحتوي اليورانيوم
المنظم ويقلل من اهميه هجوم اوكرانيا
المضاد
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره اخباريه من العربيه قال الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب امام انصاره
في نيوجيرسي قال ان اليوم يعد يوما هو
الاكثر شرا بتاريخ الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وانما حصل خلال محاكمته اضطهاد
سياسي كما اضفت ترامبلا امريكا ستتذكر هذا
اليوم وانها ستتذكر كذلك ان جو بايدن رئيس
فاسد بسبب استغلاله للسلطه استكمل حديثه
قائلا ايضا ان هناك قضايا سابقا لم ينظر
اليها من قبل القضاء مثل قضيه احتفاظ هلال
كلينتون بوثائق سريه هذا واضاف ترامب
قائلا اننا تدمير الدوله العميقه هدف له
في حال عودته الرئاسات وانه سيعين محققا
خاصا لملاحقه بايدن قضائيا
دونالد ترامب يغادر فلوريدا الى نيوجيرسي
بعد نهار حافل قضاه الرئيس الامريكي
السابق في ميامي حيث دافع ببراءته مع
انطلاق جلسه المحاكمه في 37 تهمه متعلقه
باساءه التعامل مع اسرار حكوميه
المدعي الفيدرالي الخاص جاكس ميث سمح
لترامب بمغادره المحكمه من دون شروط
الذي التقى بمناصريه في ميامي بعد الجلسه
عبر عن اسفه لما ال اليه حال الولايات
المتحده
اظن ان الامور تسير على ما يرام فالقضيه
برايي ملفقه لدينا دوله فاشله ليس لفسادها
حدود وتعاني من كثره المشاكل نحن امه في
حاله انحدار ثم ياتون بعد ذلك ويرفعون
قضيه ضدي ولكنكم ترون كيف تقف الحشود بصفي
وكيف تحبني وتؤيدني بلدنا يتدهور كما لم
يحصل من قبل ولا يمكننا ان ندعى ذلك يحدث
انصار ترامب احتشدوا في نادي الجولف في
بادمنستر في ولايه نيوجيرسي حيث القى كلمه
ردا على الاتهامات الموجهه اليه متهما
الرئيس الامريكي الحالي جو بايدن بمحاوله
سرقه الانتخابات
اليوم شهدنا اكثر نهار فيه شر في تاريخ
بلادنا لم نرى يوما رئيسا سابقا يتعرض على
يد خصومه لما عشته اليوم كل هذا في خضم
الانتخابات والسباق الرئاسي هذا ما يسمى
بالتدخل في الانتخابات من اجل سرقتها
والاهم من ذلك انه اضطهاد سياسي واضح وهو
من خصال الدول الفاشيه والشيوعيه سنتذكر
هذا اليوم وسنتذكر ان الرئيس بايدن هو
الاكثر فسادا وهو محاط بزمره من الاشخاص
تسعى لقتل الديمقراطيه الامريكيه لكنهم
سيفشلون وسنفوز في النهايه
كلمات ناريه اطلقها ترامب على خصمه بايدن
معتبرا محاكمته سوء استغلال شرير وشنيع
للسلطه في امريكا
هذا وافاد موقع اكسيوس الاخباري ان القاضي
جاكس مثل لم يفرض قيودا على سفر رئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب كجزء من
شروط ما قبل المحاكمه ونقل الموقع على
الخبير في جامعه ميامي كريكت روسينو قوله
انه في ظل الظروف العاديه يمكن للقاضي ان
يامر المدعية المدعي عليه بتقديم تعهد او
تقييد سفر لكن ترامب كونه شخصيه يسهل
التعرف عليها ويشارك في حملته الانتخابيه
لن يوجد هناك خطر منه به
وفي اول رد فعل بعد محاكمه رئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب رئيس الامريكي الحالي
جو بايدن وفي رد على احد الصحفيين خلال
حفل استقبال رؤساء البعثات بالجناح الشرقي
للبيت الابيض رفض التعليق على اي تفاصيل
تتعلق بمحاكمه دونالد ترامب
سال رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكيه سيناتور
الجمهوري كيفن ماكارتي في حوار مع
الصحفيين ان كان اي واحد منهم قد سال
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن عن الوثائق
السريه التي كان يحتفظ بها والتي تعود
للفتره التي كان يشغل فيها منصب سيناتور
ديمقراطي
اطالب بالمساواه هل سال احدكم الرئيس
الحالي بايدن لماذا احتفظ بوثائق سريه
خارج مرفق المعلومات الحساسه والمجزاه
عندما كان يشغل منصب سيناتور هل فعل احدكم
ذلك لماذا اصلا كانت لديه هذه الوثائق بغض
النظر عن انه اعادها لاحقا
بعد محاكمه في ميامي سيناريوهات سعيد
تنتظر دونالد ترامب منها طلب لرفع القضيه
واجراءات محاكمه تصل الى عام واكثر
[موسيقى]
قال صحيفه الوش الامريكيه السابق دونالد
ترامب يواجه صعوباتهم في العثور على
محامين لتمثيله في المحكمه حول الوثائق
السريه ارجعت الصحيفه الامر لاحداث جرت
بين ترامب ومحامين اخرين في العديد من
القضايا السابقه
واجهت رامب معضله في العثور على محام مؤهل
من فلوريدا للانضمام الى فريق دفاعه
واشنطن بوست قالت ان محامين بارزين في
فلوريدا رفضوا الترافع عن ترامب بعد
استقاله اثنين من محاميه الرئيسيين
الاسبوع الماضي
اضافت الصحيفه ان ترامب امض يوم الاثنين
في مقابلات مع محامين محتملين والاجتماع
بفريقه القانوني ومستشاريه لمناقشه القضيه
مستشار لترامب اشار الا ان التوت بلانش
سيقود فريق الدفاع كما فعل في قضيه ترامب
في نيويورك
خبراء قالوا لواشنطن بوست ان ترامب يعاني
في تعيين المحامين منذ انتخابه رئيسا عام
2016 بعدما عرف عنه تجنب المشوره
القانونيه احيانا وعدم الدفع لمحاميه في
احيان اخرى
شكرا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
انفجارات في محيط دمشق ومصادر تتحدث عن
قصف اسرائيلي لموقع عسكري بريف العاصمه
السوريه
اهلا بكم من جديد الى تطورات الميدانيه في
السودان حيث كشفت مصادر عسكريه عن مقتل
عدد من الضباط والجنود والاطباء بالاضافه
الى مرضى بعد هجمات بمسيره على مقر رئاسه
سلاح المدرعات والمشفى الملحق به في منطقه
الشجره بجنوب الخرطوم
الى ذلك قال الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو غوتيريش ان هناك تقارير تتحدث عن
اعمال عنف واسعه النقاط او واسعه نطاق
وسقوط ضحايا في جميع انحاء اقليم دارفور
في السودان لا سيما في الجنينه بولايه غرب
دارفور وعبر غوتيرج في بيان صحفي عن القلق
الشديد بشان البعد العرقي المتزايد لاعمال
العنف وكذلك من التقارير عن العنف الجنسي
هذا وجد داغوتيرج دعوته للقوات المسلحه
السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع الى وقف
القتال والالتزام بوقف دائم للاعمال
العدائيه
في العشرين من مايو الماضي كشفت العربيه
في تقرير استقصائي عن وفاه اكثر من 30
طفلا من حديثي الولاده بمستشفى الضعين
بشرق دارفور اليوم وبعد قرابه الشهرين من
تسليط الضوء على القضيه عاده كاميرا
العربيه الى المستشفى مجددا ورصدات
استجابه السلطات المحليه والمنظمات لتحسين
ظروف الرعايه بقسم الاطفال بالمستشفى
[موسيقى]
العنابر شبه خاليه بسبب الاستجابه السريعه
للعلاج كهرباء الحمد لله يتوفرت الناس
الان الانخفاض يعني الوفيات يتخفضت
ويتقللت يمكن اقول لك بعد اسبوع يمكن يكون
حاله وفاه يمكن يكون واحده او اقل من وما
زالت المبادرات المجتمعيه تعمل داخل
المستشفى وهذه هي جامعه الضعين وغرفه
الطوارئ تنفذ حمله للنظافه ونقل النفايات
المقدسه منذ فتره طويله داخل المستشفى
تدخلنا ان شاء الله بعض الايات انه يحاول
تحاول ردمها وحرقها والتخلص منها ان شاء
الله المبادره حتنطلق مع مبادره غرفه
طوارئ انه نحاول انه نعمل غرف ان شاء الله
ببعض الاطراف المدينه زي معسكر النيم زي
معسكر خوري وعمر لان في اقتصار سكاني كبير
جدا ننتظر للمحليات ويواجه مستشفى الضعين
ضغطا كبيرا في الخدمات المقدمه نسبه
لزيارات المتعدده للمرضى من مختلف
الولايات السودان الشيء الذي يحتاج الى
دعم اكبر خلال هذه الفتره صالح ابو علامه
لقناتي العربيه والحدث اقليم دارفور غربيه
السودان
[موسيقى]
سمع دوي في الجراثيم المتتاليه في العاصمه
السوريه دمشق ناجمه عن قصف اسرائيلي
استهدف مواقع عسكريه في محيط العاصمه دمشق
تحدث مصدر محلي للعربيه ان احد المواقع
المستهدفه هو مقر عسكري في محيط منطقه
الكسوه فيري في دمشق ما ادى الى اشتعال
النيران ادت الغارات الاسرائيليه بحسب
مصدر عسكري سوري الى اصابه جنديا بجروح
خطره ووقوع خسائر ماديه
بعد حديث وزير الطاقه في حكومه تصريف
الاعمال في لبنان وليد فياض عن ان مخيمات
اللجوء لا تدفع فواتير الكهرباء ملمحا الى
امكانيه قطع الكهرباء عنها جالت كاميرا
العربيه في عدد من هذه المخيمات لتكشف ان
بعضها يدفع الفواتير بطريقه نظاميه على
عكس ما قاله الوزير اما البعض الاخر فحال
ظروفهم المعيشيه الامكانيه دفع فواتير
الكهرباء مؤكدين انها مسؤوليه المجتمع
الدولي
في هذه الصناديق عدادات الكهرباء الموصوله
الى خيام اللاجئين في احد مخيمات البقاع
صناديق تناقض ما صرح به وزير الطاقه وليد
فياض بان اللاجئ في لبنان لا يدفع لقاء
كهرباء الدوله من 2014 من تاريخ المخيم
ركبنا ساعه كامله لكل المخيم وكل قيمه لها
عدادها
وكل قيمه بتدفع للبلديه شو بيطلع عليها
على العداد
سوره الكهرباء بالعداد السابق والعداد
الحالي وشوف يطلع شو طالع عليك مبلغ
هي الايصالات التي تنقذ ارواحهم من تنمر
اي عنصري وحاقد ومنتقد ولكن ليس الجميع
يمتلك قدره الدفع جئنا الى مخيم اخر في
منطقه اخرى هنا الوضع يختلف ليست هناك
عدادات ولا يدفع اللاجئون ثمن الكهرباء
فاي قانون يفرض على لاجئ هجر من بلاده ان
يدفع ثمن كهربائي لا تزوره الا نادرا هذه
الكبلات موصوله على اعمده الكهرباء بطريقه
غير قانونيه بفضل تناسي المجتمع الدولي
لمسؤولياته تجاه سكان المخيم بحسب اقوالهم
عم تدفعوا كهرباء شي
ليه ما بتدفعوا
كهرباء والله بشكل عام الوضع صعب كثير
وعلينا يعني ما في ناجح الا ما عليها ديون
ما عليها شيء
ما بشتغل شي كيف بدي بتعيد امورك
المدام تطلع
مندور على
مصادر وزاره الطاقه اكدت انه سيتم قطع
الكهرباء عن المخيمات مطلع شهر اغسطس في
حال لم تدفع الفواتير المتوجبه عليها اما
مصادر كهرباء لبنان فنفت علمها بوجود
مخيمات تدفع لها بالتعاون مع البلديات
وقالت انها ليس لديها هكذا عقود ناهد يوسف
العربيه بيروت
[موسيقى]
بعد توجيه من الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
غادر ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان الى فرنسا في زياره رسميه يلتقي
فيها الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون من
المقرر ان يتراسى ولي العهد السعودي وفد
المملكه المشارك في قمه من اجل ميثاق مالي
عالمي جديد المقرر عقدها في باريس يومي
الثاني والعشرين والثالث والعشرين من
يونيو
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين موسكو
ستستخدم اسلحه تحتوي على يورانيوم منظم لو
استدعت الحاجه مشيرا الى ان الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد الذي بدا في الرابع من
يونيو استهدف محاور مختلفه اضاف بوتين انه
كان على القوات الروسيه لاستعداد بشكل
افضل لصد الهجمات داخل الاراضي الروسيه
وان روسيا اجبرت في هذه الحرب على الدفاع
عن نفسها وعدم تغييره اهداف عملياتها
العسكريه كما اوضح بوتاننا خسائر روسيا
اقل بعشر مرات من خسائر اوكرانيا وان
الاخيره خسرت نحو 30% من الاليات الغربيه
وفيما يتعلق بساد نوفاكا خوفك اكد بوتين
انا قصفت السد عمدا بصواريخ مارس
اوضاع انسانيه صعبه يعاني منها سكان
المناطق التي اجتاح او اجتاحتها السيول في
خرسون نتيجه تفجير السد ومحطه نوبكار
مواطنون قادتهم الظروف الى الاقامه في غرف
المرضى بالمستشفيات رغم انهم ليسوا بمرضى
واخرون اتخذوا من المدارس ودور الثقافه
ملاذا لهم وجميعهم لا يدري متى وكيف تنتهي
هذه الكارثه
نحن هنا في مستشفى خرسون حيث المعاناه
اكبر عند اصحاب الامراض المزمنه وكبار
السن الذين فتح مستشفى خرسون ابوابه
لاستقبال النازحين منهم ومن تم اجلائهم من
مناطق الفيضان ممن يحتاجون الرعايه الصحيه
وحتى اولئك الذين لا يحتاجون اليها ولكنهم
لا يجدون مسكنا فقد تم اسكانهم بشكل مؤقت
في عنابر المستشفى حتى تجد السلطات حللا
لاوضاعهم
في الوقت الحالي في القطاع يوجد 51 شخصا
منهم من يحتاج الى رعايه الصحيه هنا يوجد
من تم تنويمهم وفي الطوابق الاعلى يوجد
اشخاص لا يحتاجون الى الرعايه تم تسكينهم
ولكن على الرغم من ذلك اذا كانت لديهم اي
شكوى كارتفاع الضغط او الصداع نقدم لهم
المساعده تحدثنا الى بعض المواطنين
المقيمين في المستشفى كالجده الله التي
فقد زوجها منذ اعوام وتعيش وحيده غمرت
المياه منزلها بالكامل واتلفت الاثاث
وجميع ممتلكاتها ولا تدري ما حل بالمنزل
بعد ان تم اجلائها
في الصباح استيقظنا على سياح رجل كان يصرخ
اخرج سنساعدكم لان المياه اتيه منك خفقه
وستغرقون
بدات عمليه الاجلاء وانا معاق لذلك قررت
الانتظار لم اكن اعتقد ان المياه يمكنها
الوصول الى هذا الارتفاع ولكن اضطررت الى
الاتصال بجارتي التي طلبت الدفاع المدني
والذين اتوا واخرجوني بصعوبه
الفيضان اغرق مساحات واسعه حيث لا تزال 46
بلده مغموره بالمياه معظمها في الضفه
اليمنى حيث سيطره الاوكرانيين والبقيه في
مناطق سيطره الروس الا ان المعاناه واحده
فقد الناس حياتهم وممتلكاتهم واصبحوا
نازحين يعيشون على الاعانات الانسانيه
تداعيات الكارثه البيئيه لا يمكن التنبؤ
بها ومصير الاف البيوت وممتلكات الناس ما
زال مجهولا وتحذر السلطات من دخول مناطق
الفيضان حتى بعد انحسار المياه خوفا من
الالغام التي غطاها الطنيو واصبح من الصعب
الكشف عنها ولا احد يتحدث عن عوده قريبه
لمن اجبرهم الفيضان على نزوح ضيف عادل
العربيه من مدينه خرسون
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان الولايات
المتحده ستستمر بالدفاع عن اراضي النيتو
وستقدم ما يكفي من الدعم لمساعده اوكرانيا
في دفاعها عن اراضيها
لان نظيره وروسي بلادي اخفقه خلال محاولته
ابعادها عن الحلف وانه يعمل بانضمام
السويد قريبا
الشرقي واوضحنا اننا سندافع عن كل شبر من
اراضيه واكرر ان التزامنا بالماده الخامسه
لحلف الناتو قوي للغايه وسوف نبقي على هذا
الزخم خلال قمه ليتوانيا الشهر المقبل
وسنعمل مع الحلفاء ونقدم كافه الامكانيات
للدفاع عن اوكرانيا الرئيس الروسي اخطا
بحساباته عندما كان يحاول ابعاد فنلندا عن
النيتو لكن النتيجه جاءت عكسيه ونامل ايضا
بانضمام السويد الى الحلف قريبا
كشفت شرطه من الضحايا جرائم قتل ارتكبها
شخص في الحاديه والثلاثين من العمر قيد
الاعتقال لهم طالب وطالبه في التاسعه عشره
من العمر ورجل خمس سنين قالت الشرطه انها
لا تبحث عن اي جنات اخرين
الخامسه والنصف صباحا بالتوقيت المحلي كان
شارع ملتا حيث اقف الان مسرحا لجريمه
مروعه حيث قام شخص يستقل حافله صغيره بدهس
عده اشخاص نقل ثلاثه منهم للمستشفى
لكن مدينه التي تبعد 130 ميلا شمال غربي
لندن كانت مسرحا لعمليه الطعن الساعه
الرابعه فجرا في شارع الكستن الذي يبعد
كيلومترين فقط عن هنا بعد ذلك اصبح شارع
مجدله مسرحا لجريمه اخرى حيث وجدت جثه في
الشارع
انا على بعد 25 ثانيه مشيا عن المكان الذي
وقعت فيه احدى الجرائم اشعر بحجم تغطيه
الاعلاميه والرجال الشرطه الامر كان مرعبا
بالنسبه الي
انه لامر
مروع صدمه كبيره لكننا ما زلنا ناتي الى
وسط المدينه ولم نفهم ما حدث حتى الان
الشرطه المحليه ووحده مكافحه الارهاب
وقوات امنيه مسلحه ومقنعه في مشهد قل
نظيره في شوارع بريطانيا احتلت شوارع
مدينه ناطنينغام لساعات طويله اضافه الى
عشرات من سيارات الطوارئ والاطفاء كل
التفصيل مهم في هذه التحقيقات الضخمه من
كاميرات المراقبه في الشوارع الى استجواب
المعتقل حتى مداهمات عده نفذتها الشرطه
المحليه فيما حبست المدينه انفسها خوفا من
هجمه اخرى من مسرح الجريمه في مصطفى زارو
العربيه
[موسيقى]
قال الجيش الياباني اثنين من جنوده قتلوا
جرى حادث اطلاق نار بميدان العسكري
للرمايه في مقاطعه جيفو بوسط اليابان ذكرت
وسائل الاعلام اليابانيه انه تم القاء
القبض على عنصر من قوات الدفاع الذات
للاشتباه في قيامه باطلاق نار وان هناك
ثلاثه مصابين
لقي اكثر من مئه شخص اسرعهم جراء غرقي
قارب في نهر في نيجيريا كان ينقل عائلتنا
عائده من حفل زفاف من ولايه النيجر الى
منطقه
الشرطه ان الفرق المختصه تمكنت من انقاذ
100 شخص فيما لا تزال عمليات البحث
والانقاذ مستمره مرجحه ارتفاع حصيله
القتلى تعد حوادث القوارب النهريه شائعه
في نيجيريا وعاده ما تكون ناجمه عن
الحمولات الزائده او سوء الصيانه او تجاهل
قواعد السلامه والفيضانات الغزيره خلال
موسم الامطار
الى العناوين
في خطاب امام منصره بعد وصوله امام
المحكمه ترامب يعتبر قضيه الوثائق محاوله
لتزوير الانتخابات المقبله
قتلو وجرح بهجمات طائرات مسيره استهدفت
مقر سلاح المدرعات في الخرطوم
وتاني يهدد باستخدام اسلحه تحتوي
اليورانيوم المنظم ويقلل من اهميه هجوم
اوكرانيا
في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات